Candid Truth.
>> What is up everybody? Thank you for
joining us at Candid Truth. We're going
to talk about the truth. We're going to
get candid with it. a friend of mine,
man, he reached out to me a while back
and was just connecting a lot of dots
with the Christian culture, the
Christian studios, the Christian
corporations that are out there and
proving that these companies, these
quote unquote Christian companies are
not as Christian as they appear to be.
I'm talking Angel Studios, I'm talking
Chick-fil-A, talking about a lot of
stuff. And and we just saw with uh quote
unquote Apostle David, he just got
arrested for a $50 million
trafficking organization going on. So
there's there's so much stuff coming out
right now about Christians being exposed
for not being Christians. Satan is
infiltrating the church. He's
infiltrating the body of Christ. And
it's amazing to see how the Christian
world really doesn't use discernment. I
I'll admit there are some of these
things that are very convincing, very
convincing and but but it's so easy to
really just dig. You know, my friend, he
was like, "Look, um I just looked up who
is this who is this person associated
with?" And I'm starting to see the the
hands joined together and there are some
very concerning things. So, check this
out. Everybody knows Chick-fil-A as this
Christian corporation. When you look up,
does Chick-fil-A have Christian
standards, the the answer that shows up
says yes. Chick-fil-A and operates on
Christian principles and morals rooted
in the belief of its founder, Truit
Kathy. So, this is the Kathy family.
Kathy and it says corporate purpose is
to glorify God and have a positive
influence, which is a clear indicator of
his Christian foundation. So Chick-fil-A
is trying to glorify God and have a
positive positive influence closing on
Sundays. That that's a whole different
topic right there. But look, a lot of
Christians observe Sunday. They go to
church on Sunday. And so the owner of
this company said, "Look, I'm going to
close on Sunday so that people can rest
and go to church." church. It says right
here, "The company famously closes its
restaurant on Sundays to allow employees
to attend church and rest, a practice
established by the founder, Truit
Cathy." This is the the owner, the
founder, Truit Cathy. He passed away in
2021, I believe. And it says, "Our
founder, S. Truy, Truit Cathy, made the
decision to close on Sundays in 1946.
He knew what it was like to work seven
days a week in restaurants. So he saw
the importance of letting his employees
set aside one day to rest and worship if
they choose. That's a practice we still
uphold today. So a lot of people look at
Chick-fil-A and they're like, "Whoa."
Like, man, they're so honorable to keep
Sunday. I think it's really ironic
because if you're a Sabbathke keeper and
you say, "Oh, you know, I believe in
keeping the Sabbath. I don't work. I go
to church on Saturday." People are like,
"Oh, you legalist. Don't put me under
the law of Sabbath and all this." But
ironically, if you close on Sunday,
people look at you uh like, "Holy, like,
oh, you are revered in some kind of way
because you close on Sunday." The irony.
It is very ironic. So, I asked, "Is Dan
Kathy a Christian?" Because the founder
that we just looked at, he passed away.
The company was given to his son. And
you see it still says here, I said, "Is
is he a Christian?" Yes. Dan Kathy is a
Christian. He's a prominent figure in
the Southern Baptist tradition. And his
faith has influenced the company values
of Chick-fil-A, including closing on
Sundays and promoting a culture of care
and respect for employees. Here's a
breakdown of his Christian identity.
deep religious beliefs, public
affiliations. He's affiliated with
Christian organizations. Closed on
Sunday, influence on Chick-fil-A, the
company's stated purpose to glorify God
by being a faithful steward of all that
is entrusted to us. So, Dan Kathy,
he is a self-professed open Christian.
So, I was looking, does the Kathy family
own a production company?
Yes, the Kathy family owns a production
company called Trillis Studios. Trilith
Studios in Fagetville, Georgia. The
former CEO of Chick-fil-A, Dan Kathy,
co-owns and funds the studio through his
family's investment firm, Rivers Rock
LLC. So Dan Kathy is a co-owner of
Trilith Studios, a movie making company,
a film production studio.
So I would expect this to be kind of
like Angel Studios or Purix, right? Like
you're going to have all these Christian
movies coming from this company that's
owned by the CEO of Chick-fil-A, former
owner of uh Chick-fil-A.
Trilith Studios was originally founded
in 2014 as a partnership with British
studio Pinewood. The Kathy family bought
out Pinewood Stake in 2019 and renamed
it Trilith. That's interesting. So, the
studio's name was Pinewood
and they renamed it Trilith. Remember
this because Trilith is an interesting
word. Film and TV productions. Okay,
we're going to get into all that, but
yes, the Chick-fil-A family owns Trillis
Studios. Here is the website, their
official website, Trillis Studios.
They don't just own a studio, though.
They actually have like a whole town and
hotel and wellness center and
restaurants and retail and all that.
Look at this. Look at the movies that
they've produced here. We're going to
look at a whole list of them. These are
the movies that Trillis Studios
produced. The Suicide Squad.
The Suicide Squad. If you don't know
what The Suicide Squad is, it's a rated
R comic movie. I've never seen it, but
it's full of foul language, full of
murder, full of all kinds of evil things
in the movie. And that's their banner at
the top, the Suicide Squad. Like, they
take pride in producing the Suicide
Squad. Superman, you know, there's going
to be a lot of these that people are
going to say, "Oh, there's nothing wrong
with Superman or whatever." But Superman
is an antichrist. He um has all the
characteristics of Christ, you know, he
his father sent him to earth to be the
savior of earth and yet he shacks up
with Lois and he doesn't have the
mission that Christ has to
um save people from their sins, right?
And so what do you call somebody that is
looks a whole lot like Christ but
doesn't have the same mission? That's
antichrist, right? He looks close to
Christ but he's not Christ. and he does
sinful behaviors.
A lot of these I never even heard of.
Iron Hart, but it's notice it's Disney
and Marvel and DC. These are all the and
Netflix. These are all the people that
have worked with Trillis Studios. This I
don't know what Agatha
is, but I see the one eye symbolism. It
looks very witchy. I'm just assuming
here. Uh, Guardians of the Galaxy,
Werewolf by Night. What kind of movies
are these for Christians to be
producing? Haunted Mansion,
Black Adam. Black Adam was definitely
about putting Satan on the throne. But
again, these are more kind of
undertones, you know, things that aren't
right there in the open. Maybe to some
can't see that.
But all of this, the majority of these
movies are
Disney, Marvel, and what's Disney,
what's Disney and Marvel all about?
Promoting the LGBTQ lifestyle, uh,
promoting witchcraft, promoting follow
your heart, do what thou wilt,
zombie land.
Like, this is insane. When I started
seeing these, I was like, "This is crazy
that this is owned by a Christian
studio,
uh, Passenger. I'm not sure the rating
of this movie, but I remember my wife
talking about it that there was, um, you
know, a sex scene in in the movie. The
Avengers, Infinity War, these movies are
making Christ the villain. Thanos is
Christ. He sits on a throne in a
spaceship called the sanctuary and he's
coming to Earth to snap his finger and
separate the sheep from the goats,
destroying half of humanity. So, this is
this is just a shocker right here.
Notice their logo here.
You see this like arch this like
infinity arch or thing, whatever that
is. We're going to look into the name of
this. Um, this is actually their their
dwelling places. You can live at Trilith
in apartments.
And what is this? It says green space.
And to me, this looks like a labyrinth.
Is that a labyrinth? Look at what a
labyrinth is. This is This is crazy.
This is what a Christian is putting in
their community.
the art and the sculptures.
Come on, guys. I don't want to feel I
don't want to seem like I'm like
reaching or something, but this looks
like a portal. Looks like a Stargate.
One of the ancient Stargates that are
out there. They have their own school.
You know, if you've watched the the
seven mountain mandate that we did with
Minnow, you would see that right now
Christians are trying to take over
everything with a a seven mountain
mandate. all these mega churches,
they're trying to take over
entertainment, public schools,
government. And when you do that, when
you take over everything, including
government, when you're mixing religion
and the government together, that's bad
news. And that's what actually what the
Bible predicts is going to happen. What
the Bible prophesies is going to happen
is a one world religion under the guise
of Christianity. It's going to look like
peace and safety and unity and coexist
and love and all these things, but it's
going to be compromising the truth of
God. It's going to be like, oh, your way
is just a different way to God. But we
can all agree like we all believe in
God, right? We just got different
languages to God as the Pope said before
he died, right? That's what is coming. A
future. It's not going to be um the
occult is one world religion. This is
this is all propaganda. the the Left
Behind movies that said, "Oh, the
Antichrist, he's this villainous guy and
he's going to be killing Christians in
the street." No, it's going to look so
close to the truth that only the elect
will not be deceived. Only those who
stand on thus sayeth the Lord. But there
will be many who say, "Didn't we
prophesy in your name? Didn't we do many
great wonders and works in your name?"
And he'll say, "Depart from me. I never
knew you, you workers of iniquity or
lawlessness."
But they claim to be Christians. There's
a a parable of 10 virgins, right?
Virgins represent God's people, the
church. They all had oil in their lamps.
They all fell asleep. And when they woke
up, only half of them had enough oil or
the Holy Spirit to make it to that
wedding, the wedding of Christ.
This is the day and age that we are
living in right now. Look what Trillis
says. This is their own personal
Instagram page. And it says, "People ask
us all the time, why Trilithth?" Look,
you see these archways
going on. Um, oh, I didn't even know
that picture was there till just now.
Why trilith? What is a trilith? How do
you pronounce that? We get asked all
these questions and more on a daily
basis. By definition, a trilith is a
megalithic monument
consisting of three large stones, two
upright with a horizontal stone resting
upon them, just like Stonehinge in the
UK.
For us, this provides a nod to our roots
and serves as a metaphor for Trilith
Studios, representing our three pillars
of business, content, technology, and
faculties.
Okay, man. There's like
way better ways to represent your three
pillars of business than to use a pagan
altar
where ritual sacrifices happen. This is
crazy. I'm going to show you. I I cannot
believe that they actually included the
picture of
Stonehenge right there. This really just
cut out my work because I thought I was
going to have to like prove to people
that this is what it was. But I asked
Google define trilith. It says a trilith
is a megalithic monument consisting of
three large stones just like we read
about. The famous one being uh the term
derived from Greek meaning three stones.
Famous example is Stonehenge.
Here's where it's talking about it. Now
it says examples Stonehinge.
Bailbeck.
Look at that Bale. The tr the trilithon
at Baalik is another significant example
featuring massive stones forming part of
the temple of Jupiter Bale's podium
wall.
This is insane. Why, if you are a
Christian company, why would you make
your logo that represents who you are a
pagan ba worship monument?
I mean, what? Include a cross in there.
Include something Christian or something
that has nothing to do with paganism.
You know what? When you look around at
mega corporations, you're going to see a
lot of the simil a lot of similar
symbolism in their corporate logos.
Eyeballs,
pyramids or triangles,
stars, which are really pentagrams, and
the sun, always the sun. And you'll see
a lot of those changes over over the
years. You'll see the the logo will
change. Remember, Walmart used to be a a
star. Let me let me just show you this
real quick.
Walmart logo change. I want to show you
something. It used to be Walmart, wall
hyphen mart, wall hyphen mart. Then they
changed their hyphen to a star, which
was already going in the right
direction. Then they changed it to a
sixpointed sun symbol. Six-ointed hexog
sun. Now look at this BP. Do you guys
remember that BP logo used to be a green
shield and that green shield turned into
a green sun? Now, I'm not It's not It's
not like a It's a flower and I'm just
saying it's a sun. It is a sun. You can
look at the official
um that they're right there. The sunlike
shape right here. When you look at the
official the official BP
website, they'll they'll tell you openly
that their logo turned it to the sun.
When I talk about eyeballs and py
pyramids and things like that, so you
got Time Warner is a hypnotic eye, you
got speaking of hypnotic, um you have
CBS logo right here, which is an
eyeball.
How many logos have to be an eye, a
triangle? I mean, just look at banks,
gas companies, some of the ones that
make the most money. Why? Because they
are telling you who they serve. Now, if
Satan comes along and says, "Hey, I'll
make you rich and famous. All you got to
do is bow down and worship me and I'll
make you a god on this earth." And
someone takes that offer and they
actually become successful, do you think
they're do you think they're not going
to give thanks to who made them
successful? Any Christian who makes it
successful, they always give God the
glory, right? Chick-fil-A, they're
supposed to be giving God the glory
because
in their minds, and maybe that maybe God
really did make them successful in the
beginning, but something has happened
along the way where now God doesn't get
the glory, Baal gets the glory.
The pagan altar of Baal. I just think
that is crazy.
So I said, "Is a trilith used in
religious rituals?" Yes, triliths were
used in religious rituals, but their
specific functions vary depending on the
culture and locations as stone
structures built by ancient people.
Their exact purpose is often a matter of
archaeological interpretation, but
evidence suggests ritual use in many
different places. Stonehinge,
uh, they talk about Stonehenge here.
They talk about the Bronze Age,
South Arabia,
megalithic
temples of Malta.
That's interesting. Knights of Malta,
Tonga, Egypt. So, which of these nations
were known for being Christian? Was it
Egypt? Was it Tonga? Was it Malta?
I don't know. Like, I'm still I'm still
trying to figure out why would you use a
trilith as your logo for a Christian
production, a Christian production
company? What kind of rituals happen at
Stonehinge? Rituals at Stonehenge are
primarily centered on solstice
celebrations. You know what solstice is,
right? Sun worship. I think it's
interesting that here's a man that owns
a company that closes on Sunday who goes
on to own a production company who uses
the logo for Stonehinge
which is all about solstice celebration
where the druids and pagans gathered to
honor the cycle of life, death, and
rebirth by performing ceremonies at dawn
often involving chanting drums and
prayers to the rising sun.
summer solstice.
Very, very, very interesting. There's
all a connection happening here. I asked
Google, when did Sunday become part of
Christian tradition?
And it gave the proper answer. It said
Constantine's decree in 321 AD. Emperor
Constantine
issued a civil decree making Sunday a
day of rest from labor. This formalized
the existence the existing religious
practice and connected the Christian
Lord's day with the ancient Jewish
concept of the Sabbath. Now this is
where AI is actually
just grabbing information from all over
the internet. There's nothing in the
Bible that talks about keeping Sunday.
The Lord's day as it mentioned is only
mentioned once in all of the Bible. And
when you read Revelation, it's where
John says,"I was in the spirit on the
Lord's day." Now, if you read the rest
of the Bible and you try to figure out,
well, what day is the Lord's day, it's
going to say, "For the seventh day is
the Sabbath of the Lord thy God. I am
the Lord of the Sabbath." So, if the
Lord has a day, it's the Sabbath day
that he blessed and hallowed at
creation. So this emperor Constantine
what happened was when he was killing
Christians the martyr's blood were
causing more Christians to appear. So
for one every one Christian that was
killed 10 more Christians popped up and
Constantine said well if you can't beat
them join them. So he said I'll control
their system of worship. I can't kill
this thing. I'm gonna control it. I'm
gonna say, "Yes, you Christians can
worship because I've actually had a a
Christian conversion myself." And he
tells this story of seeing a red cross
in the sky and he starts painting red
crosses on his soldiers shields. And
whether that was a true scenario or not,
Satan has the power to give you visions
when you are a pagan like Constantine.
And now he was being used by the enemy
to control to change and control
Christian worship away from thus sayeth
the Lord the fourth commandment and you
will keep Sunday holy because that's
what Constantine did. He actually made
it a law
constantine
Sunday law. He made it a law to keep
Sunday,
the venerable day of the sun, a
mandatory public day of rest for city
dwellers and craftsmen in the Roman
Empire. And he also said that he said
the decree did not ban the Sabbath, but
promoted the civil observance of Sunday.
Now, that's not true either. It actually
said that those who are caught Judaizing
would be killed. You guys have to
research this yourself, guys. Man,
please research.
Research everything that we're talking
about on this channel. Everything that
we talk about here is because we're on a
journey for truth, the candid truth, and
we want to grow with you guys. We want
you guys to research this stuff. So,
check out
uh Constantine Sunday laws. The Sabbath
day was banned because they were called
Judaizers.
So, here's a question right here. Was
The Conjuring 3: The Devil Made Me Do It
shot at Trilis Studios? Yes. Notice it
wasn't in that list of movies on their
official website. I wonder why. The
Conjuring is super satanic. It says,
"Yes, The Conjuring, The Devil Made Me
Do It, was shot at Trillis Studios."
Now, if you think ah, you know, AI can
actually give wrong answers. This is the
movie, by the way, with the inverted
cross. The whole thing has to do with
demonic possession and actually fighting
demonic possession through Catholicism.
It's basically the movie The Exorcist
repackaged and it has a bunch of movies.
But if you think AI is giving false
information, check this out. Trillis
Studios, Instagram, we're counting down
the days till Halloween. They're excited
about Halloween, the most satanic
holiday that uh is observed by America.
If you need us, we'll be telling ghost
stories in one of our favorite set
pieces gifted by the produ by
production, a gazebo from the Conjuring,
The Devil Made Me Do It. They're
admitting right there that this
Christian-owned
production company was gifted this
gazebo by The Conjuring: The Devil Made
Me Do It because they filmed the movie
there.
I remember years ago that Jim Henson
actually cut ties with Chick-fil-A for
their stance on homosexuality because as
Christians, Chick-fil-A, they shut down
on Sunday and they took a strong stance
against gay marriage. And I remember
they used to have uh they were selling
little Jim Henson Muppet toys. Well,
they had to recall all the toys and
their public announcement was that it
was for a factory defect or something,
but in reality, the Jim Henson Company
cuts ties with Chick-fil-A in January
2012 or July 2012 after Chick-fil-A, a
president
uh Dan Kathy voiced opposition to gay
marriage, which conflicted with Jim
Henson's company company's commitment to
diversity and inclusiveness.
So right here we see that they they were
against homosexuality. It made the news.
Look, Muppet Company severs ties with
Chick-fil-A over gay marriage. ABC News,
Jim Henson Company splits with
Chick-fil-A over gay rights. So this was
a big deal.
And now
Chick-fil-A has a company represented by
a bail alter who makes movies like The
Conjuring and many others because I
asked I've never seen these movies. I
just picked a couple that I thought
maybe. And I said, "Is there any LGBTQ
representation in the television program
I Can See Your Voice?" That was one of
them listed on Trillis page. Yes. The
reality competition show I Can See Your
Voice has featured LGBTQ plus
contestants. The show's format requires
guest stars and blah blah blah blah
blah. So yes, now Trillis Studio Now
Chick-fil-A is no longer opposing gay
marriage, but promoting it through
propaganda that they are producing
with their logo that represents a pagan
altar. Like I just I can't emphasize
that enough. I'm just still mind blown
that that is the logo they chose to
represent their company, these
god-fearing Christians
who say they're Baptists and all this
stuff. Is there any LGBTQ representation
in Guardians of the Galaxy movie? Yes,
the postredits scenes of Guardians of
the Galaxy Volume 3 introduces the
lesbian character Phel.
Um, while the film itself does not
feature significant LGBTQ storylines,
the addition of Phil adds queer
representation to the MCU and that gets
a big applaud from the GLAD
who are always making sure there there
must be LGBTQ representation in
everything.
That's actually what they say in
everything, even children's books.
There's another movie they or a show
called Miss Marvel. Is there any LGBTQ
representation in the series Miss
Marvel? Yes, Miss Marvel includes LGBTQ
plus representation through the
character of Zoe Zimmer, who is a
lesbian classmate of Kamla Khan.
So look, what we're showing you here is
that you cannot just trust every person
that comes under the guise of, "Oh, I'm
a Christian. We own a Christian company.
We close on Sunday. Can't you tell we're
very Christian?" You must be a fruit
inspector. Jesus didn't say, "You will
know them because they go to church on
Sunday, they carry a Bible under their
arm, and they wear a cross." He said,
"You will know them by their fruit."
That's so important because Satan will
have people that will disguise
themselves as Christians. They will
infiltrate the church. They will corrupt
it. They will shape it. And it will be a
completely different church than what
the apostles started. I think it already
is. I think we're already there. I don't
trust any denomination anymore. I think
all of them have been infiltrated.
And you can look the majority of
churches are observing the venerable day
of the sun and they are in opposition to
the Sabbath. Don't you dare put me under
that legalistic law of spending time
with God on the day he made holy. It's
it's a complete contradiction. You can't
call a day of rest works. And yet that's
what people will say. and they're under
these 501c3
taxexempt forms. Like when you look into
that stuff, the government actually has
some say in what you say behind the
pulpit. There are churches who are
required to turn in their transcripts,
which now you don't have to do that
because everybody live streams and AI is
actually transcribing every word you say
and I'm sure everything's just being red
flagged and sent to whoever it needs to
be sent to. It can label you for hate
speech. Look up Southern Poverty Law
Center. Look at the hate maps. Southern
Poverty Law Center. If you look at the
hate maps, you will find that they
include people in here like churches and
religious groups, calling them hate
groups. So, this is where we're at when
the government can say, "Hey, you're not
allowed to read from that part of the
Bible because it actually condemns this
minority group over here, and that's
hate speech.
What I think is interesting is that as a
white male,
I'm told that I have white privilege and
yet I don't really see any privileges
protecting my belief system or anything
like that when my belief system and my
God is mocked, blasphemed, ridiculed
over and over and over in Hollywood. And
yet, if anyone were to say anything
remotely demeaning towards this minority
group over here, that's hate speech. You
could be fined. You could go to jail. If
you don't make a cake for this person,
we're going to shut your place down.
And yet, those same minorities could
probably say, "We're not going to make a
cake for your uh baptism. Are you
kidding me? Your belief system disagrees
with mine." and therefore we refuse to
make your cake. This is interesting
times we live in. So looking at all this
stuff makes me think of 1 Timothy 6:10.
For the love of money is the root of all
evil.
Chick-fil-A, a company that used to
stand up against the LGBTQ movement, who
closes on Sunday, who claims to be this
Christian organization,
and now they have sold out with a
company represented by a Bale altar
and producing propaganda that promotes
witchcraft,
sorcery, Antichrist messages, and
homosexual representation. The love of
money is the root of all evil.
Mark 8:36 says, "For what shall it
profit a man if he shall gain the whole
world and lose his own soul?"
You cannot put a price on eternal life.
You can't buy another day of life. You
can't buy another breath given by the
lifegiver himself.
You cannot take money or any physical
possession to heaven with you. It's all
going to burn and rust. That's why the
Bible says, "Store up your treasures in
heaven, not on earth." Because we can't
take any of this with us. The whole
mission for us on this earth is to
spread the gospel, to spread life, to
spread the light. You know what they
said? Chick-fil-A said that their whole
mission statement was to glorify God and
to be an a good influence in the world.
Where is it? Where's the good influence?
I think these people have been corrupted
by the love of money.
Matthew 7:22 says, "Many will say to me
in that day, Lord, Lord, have we not
prophesied in thy name? and in thy name
have cast out devils, and in thy name
done many wonderful works. These are
people who are Christians, claim to be
Christians. And then will I profess unto
them, I never knew you. Depart from me,
ye that work iniquity or lawlessness.
Anyone who says, I believe in Jesus, but
doesn't obey him, is lawless, and they
will be spewed from his mouth. That's
the next or that's yeah that's the next
verse here. Revelation 3:16.
So then because thou art lukewarm and
neither cold nor hot, I will spew or
vomit thee out of my mouth.
It's going to be a scary day when the
Lord returns
and people are not living right.
Christians who proclaim to be followers
of him are not doing what he would do.
What would Jesus do? Would Jesus produce
this trash?
No, he would not. 100% he would not. 2
Corinthians 11:3
says, "For such are false apostles,
deceitful workers, transforming
themselves into apostles of Christ."
This is saying that there will be people
on earth that are appearing to be
apostles of Christ. And I think this is
interesting with this apostle that just
got arrested over this $50 million
scandal. There will be false apostles,
deceitful workers transforming
themselves into apostles of Christ. What
about Satan himself?
And no marvel. Interesting marvel. And
no marvel for Satan himself
is transformed into an angel of light.
I hope this was eye opening for you
guys. If it was, please give it a thumbs
up. It really helps get this video out
into their algorithm. There are a whole
lot of people that need to hear this
message because there are so many wolves
and sheep's clothing out there and we're
seeing it come out one by one. If you're
new to this channel, please hit
subscribe, click that bell notification
so you will not miss a single episode
that comes out. If you want to support
this ministry, you can do so by going to
cantruth.org.
We have a lot of different ways to give
on there. You can become a Patreon donor
as well, or you can uh find our address
to send in a check or a money order on
cantruth.org. Also, if you guys like
t-shirts, we got a lot of cool t-shirts
for you guys with Bible verses and cool
slogans like, "Be cool. Use your brain."
Because we say it's cool to use your
brain. Satan's trying to make people
dumb because dumb people are docile and
easy to control, easy to brainwash, and
we're all about breaking that system. We
love you guys. We thank you guys. We
cannot do this without you. We'll see
you next time on Can of Truth.